oh my god dude the ending of the story
is so insane but uh but yeah okay we are
back with dark crisis guys this God the
ending of the story is so amazing all
right let's just get into it right so in
the last video we basically covered what
was an effect all the different members
of the Justice League being rescued from
their Universal prisons right where
they're basically being held but unlike
Batman or even Barry Allen who would
kind of succumb to their prison and sort
of adapted to it and then ultimately
believe that was their reality Superman
hadn't done that and in fact Superman
had absorbed basically all the energy in
his universe and become Cosmic Superman
right just this god-level Superman which
was amazing so the way that story ended
by the way the last video ended we
basically had what was in effect the
Dark Army right like the most powerful
beings in the DC Universe all of whom
were under control of pariah and the
great Darkness making their move against
what's left of the superhero community
and this is a colossal battle it's one
of the coolest things right literally
Dark Side the Specter by the the the
representation of God's vengeance wrath
or whatever in the hell role he happens
to play at this point in time in DC it
shifts all the time but like the whole
thing's nuts right so here's the thing
what this does here is it switches over
to the Justice League because remember
they're still in the realm of pariah
right they're still kind of outside the
existing Multiverse as it functions
right now but one of the things to
remember Pariah brought back the
original Multiverse now this is where I
want to take a moment I want to answer
some questions because admittedly the
story doesn't do a great job of
answering a lot of these things in a
concise way and a lot of you guys have
asked questions like okay what's going
on with the Multiverse now how does this
work what's the deal with Pariah why do
you need the superhero so on and so
forth so to answer these questions when
it comes to Pariah he is basically a guy
who originates from the original
Multiverse in DC Comics the one that was
introduced in the flash of two World
storyline back in the 1960s and the one
that was destroyed during the original
crisis on infiniters in the 1980s now
remember our discussion where we talked
in previous videos about the nature of
the crisis events that prices on
infinite Earth destroyed the Multiverse
Infinite Crisis brought the Multiverse
back and final crisis made the
superheroes aware of the multiverses
return that's still the case here right
that's still intact while DC Comics
decides to invert it what we can do is
we can call the original Multiverse that
existed before crisis on infinite Earth
we can call that Multiverse one Infinite
Crisis brought the Multiverse back but
it was a different version so we can
call that Multiverse 2.0 right
Multiverse 2. and so when it came to
Pariah because of the fact that his
desire to see the origination of
everything right how it all came into
existence because that had accidentally
unleashed the anti-monitor which led to
crisis infinite Earth that pariah's
punishment for that action was to watch
the anti-monitor destroy his home world
as well as various universes across the
Multiverse in order to basically stop
the anti-monitor and to do what he
believed would be ending his curse
Pariah had assembled the different
superheroes from across the Multiverse
and the original crisis on infinite
Earth's event which led to the defeat of
the antimon the problem with this is
that pariah's punishment remained and so
he very much became like The Watcher for
Marvel Comics where he sort of existed
out there and watched as things unfold
when the Infinite Crisis event happened
and the Multiverse came back Pariah was
excited at the idea that like his
Universe could return the problem is
that it was not his original Universe it
was a new version of his original
Universe right Multiverse two and so
he's always wanted to get back home
that's literally his motivation he's
always wanted to bring his original
universe and even the original
Multiverse back that's what's happening
here right what he did is he came to the
realization that the great darkness is
just this astronomical source of energy
that exists out there and if a person
can harness it if a person can use it
they can basically do anything they want
to but the great Darkness doesn't
believe in good or evil it's not
inherently good it's not inherently evil
the reality is that pretty much
everything that is evil in the DC
Universe originates from the great
Darkness but the great Darkness itself
is not inherently bad much in the same
way that like the presence in DC Comics
basically their version of God is not
inherently good or evil but all the good
things in the universe originate from it
right so it's it's you can kind of make
of that what you want to but the
important thing here is that when Pariah
realized that was the case and then
realized the main DC Universe is the
center of the Multiverse basically
meaning the most powerful version of the
Justice League exists in the main DC
Universe his desire was to literally
siphon their power and so that's why
over the course of this story he had
captured different members of the
Justice League and then placed them in
what were basically prison worlds right
where he gave them everything they could
ever possibly want because then they
wouldn't want to leave and that because
they were there it would allow Pariah to
siphon off all the energy of those
individual beings as well as the whole
universe and then channel that energy
into the great darkness and so
ultimately that happened and that's why
he was able to bring the original
Multiverse back that's why he said in
the last video it doesn't matter that
you freed the Justice League I have
everything that I need I got all the
power I needed in my Multiverse has
returned here's the problem I kind of
getting back into the story this is what
Barry Allen starts to realize is yes the
original Multiverse came back but
remember when it comes to different
universes and DC Comics they all vibrate
at different frequencies it's how Barry
Allen is able to travel from one
Universe to the next right if you
compare it to like musical notes the
main DC Universe vibrates at the key of
C and this other Universe vibrates at
the key of D and so if Barry Allen is in
the main DC Universe and his body
naturally vibrates in the key of C he
can actually change his body's vibration
to the key of D and then enter into that
alternate reality that's how that works
right it's like a key for him to enter
in and out of any universe that he wants
to but being so well attuned to the
vibrational frequencies of different
universes what he realizes is that this
Multiverse all these different universes
are vibrating at the wrong speed and
what that basically means is that
they're continually speeding up what
this means is that if enough time goes
by because of the fact that these
different worlds are vibrating faster
and faster eventually it'll create an
explosion literally the Multiverse that
that Pariah brought back will blow up
and when that happens it'll destroy the
existing Multiverse with it right it'll
take them both out and so the goal is to
basically find a way to stop Pariah and
then literally get rid of the Multiverse
that he brought back now a lot of people
have asked questions are there people on
these different worlds where's like the
original Superman from before crisis on
infinitas DC doesn't explain that and
the reality is because it's not
necessarily important this Multiverse is
seemingly not going to last or is it
because if you guys have been reading
the news DC is basically gonna reboot
next year so here's the thing I know I
know I know it's crazy here's the thing
so ultimately you know we basically jump
back to Earth where this massive battle
is ensuing between the different
superheroes who are here and then Pariah
and His Dark Army now what Pariah
realizes when he basically attacks like
Firestorm and he attacks like Blue
Beetle and Booster Gold in these guys
and literally teleports them away is he
starts to realize that yes the
Multiverse is not necessarily balanced
but that's because it does doesn't have
enough energy with every single
superhero that he attacks and sends to
one of these different worlds it helps
to basically balance out the new
Multiverse that he's created so
literally that's what he starts doing he
starts attacking superheroes left and
right and he orders Deathstroke like
attack as many superheroes as you can
and send them to basically this new
Multiverse that I've created and it'll
start to balance everything out right
like literally everything that I want to
happen will come to fruition now it's a
Race Against Time can the Justice League
return in time to stop Pariah from
taking out enough superheroes and
sending them to this Multiverse that
he's brought back in order to ensure
that that Multiverse can be destroyed
and Pariah annihilated along with it and
so what you do is you switch over to
Jonathan Ken now this is a moment that's
really been coming for his character for
quite some time right so God I love this
part of the story this is when things
get really really amazing check this out
so Jonathan Kent immediately goes after
Darkseid now Jonathan's outclassed by
this guy and that's one of the things to
know he hasn't faced off against
Darkseid in any meaningful way he hasn't
really even fought like Doomsday in any
meaningful way he's exceedingly capable
but as most of you guys know who have
read DC Comics for any measure of time
fighting Darkseid is not like a bar
fight right you don't just like smash a
beer bottle on the countertop and just
start pointing at people it doesn't work
that way right like you need finesse you
need the ability to understand the full
totality of what darkseid's capable of
and be able to adapt accordingly because
he has his Omega beams right even his
Omega sanction which is DC's plot device
when you want to kill off Batman but not
really so the thing about this is that
with Jonathan Kent facing off against
Darkseid he's able to hold his own to a
degree but not permanently what's even
more insane than that is that you do
have this attempt right by I can't
remember her name anymore the Brazilian
Wonder Woman right not the Diana Troy
chick but like the new Young Wonder
Woman check she literally uses the lasso
of truth that gets thrown around Pariah
and he casts it off and he literally
breaks the lasso of Truth off of himself
now for those of you guys who aren't
familiar with that that's not supposed
to happen there have been precious few
times in DC Comics when the lasso of
Truth has been over overpowered by
anybody and that's the nature of of like
Pariah here right the lasso of Truth has
been wrapped around Gods who basically
were contained by its power it's an
astronomical thing and so in this fight
against Darkseid ultimately Jonathan Kin
is initially overtaken by what is an
attack from a variety of members of the
Dark Army and then he's attacked by
doomsday and so then you get this
amazing moment where Jonathan Kent kind
of recollects on these lessons he was
taught by his father right where
Superman says I want you to make that s
your own one day son right like that's
going to be your symbol you're going to
become your own version of me don't be
me be better than me right and then like
Lois had told him at one point in time
you have the best of both worlds inside
of you you can be great you just simply
have to choose to be right it's Jonathan
Kent coming into his own and for the
longest time that never happened for the
longest time Jonathan Kent was a kid who
was like I want to be just like my dad
but the truth about this is he's not his
dad right his dad is Kryptonian he's the
last survivor from a world that was
destroyed his mom is an Earthling
Jonathan has the best of both worlds he
is by all standards of measurement
everything that his father aspires to be
he can be the best of everything and so
this guy puts up a ridiculous fight it's
like one of the most badass moments ever
for Jonathan
it's amazing right keep this guy he
takes on the combined forces of like
Darkseid doomsday all these guys and so
what this does is it leads to Mr
terrific and his guys literally
channeling the anti-matter projector of
pariah right the thing that he initially
used to cause the original crisis on
infinite Earth in the first place right
unleashing the anti-monitor that sort of
thing but this is an anti-matter device
and it is unique to Pariah meaning if
Pariah can make it Pariah can be
destroyed by it let's be honest with
ourselves in the context of this story
this thing's basically the ultimate
nullifier from Marvel Comics but it is
one of those things where it's fired by
their superheroes and it encases Pariah
and when it does it disintegrates and it
annihilates Pariah now here's a a
question you have to ask here right if
Pariah is destroyed this quickly in DC
Comics then what the hell is coming next
because I'm gonna be honest with you
guys he's kind of eradicated pretty
quickly even with everything that's gone
on it's not some Grand some great big
huge grandiose fight between Pariah and
like the Earth superheroes and it's like
the last man standing it's not even one
of those things they're just like okay
we got the antimatter projector ready
guys all right are we ready yeah fire
cool prize Dead awesome the day saved
not really man because again if you guys
are reading the news things are going to
get much much worse right like it's the
story that DC is writing that's coming
out is going to be absolutely insane but
what this did right with everything that
had happened here the idea of them even
being able to fire off the antimatter
projector and Destroy Pariah in the
first place that's because Jonathan Kent
bought them time but lest we forget
while Jonathan Kent was able to take out
a bunch of members of the of the Dark
Army doomsday is still there remember
doomsday always comes back from the
thing that killed him so Jonathan Kent's
just there like okay cool I bought them
time and at this moment he's proud to
make this sacrifice he's proud to die
right block Adam comes racing in out of
nowhere right he's just like John right
he comes racing in to try to save
Jonathan he's whisked away because while
Jonathan Kent's just sitting there and
is like I did it right I bought them the
time they needed I am exhausted I'm
ready to go I hope you're proud of me
dad he's saying this watching as
doomsday is hauling ass to him and as
you guys know man doomsday is not a guy
to be trifled with right doomsday will
kill Jonathan Kent and he won't even
think twice about it right he's more
than powerful enough to do that so
doomsday comes racing in like there's a
conference
it is a ridiculously amazing moment
right doomsday comes racing Tuesday
flying in right doomsday comes in for
the killing punch
Superman
dead in his tracks I'm like sauce
monster man popped up in the nick of
time it's like the best moment ever he's
just blocking that [ __ ] with his hands I
was like man man I saw this I'm sorry
I'm so excited people God I love this so
much better song man it's not so at that
point it's like Jonathan and Superman
side by side doomsday gets man this guy
gets hit man man he gets his cheeks clap
son it's it's funny we just
getting them cheeks clap but that's
exactly what it is right like literally
John the kid Superman they team up
they're like never again they destroy
doomsday send this guy flying right and
Superman's like I'm proud of you son
like you are everything that I ever
wanted you to be like you have become
everything that I ever wanted you to
become like you you are the superhero
that I wanted you to be this is what I
wanted you to become your own man I
didn't want you to be me I wanted you to
be your own superhero but here's the
kicker man remember Pariah is gone
Pariah is dead rise out of the picture
the Justice League shows up everybody
shows up the power of the dark Army is
fading momentarily but then it all
starts to come back and the reason why
is because the great Darkness has chosen
a new host the great Darkness has
officially been corrupted by Pariah now
right like the great Darkness didn't
used to care about Good and Evil it
never really mattered before but now
it's been corrupted and now it seemingly
wants to destroy everything the host the
great darkness is chosen is literally
Deathstroke who is amazing because
remember Deathstroke knows the strengths
and weaknesses of every single superhero
I would argue this guy is deadlier than
Pariah has ever been with that being
said guys we're gonna bring this video
to an end thank you all for watching I
will catch you all later peace